Welcome to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, the history of Denmark, Episode One: from the Vikings to the absolute monarchy.
Let's begin with a remarkable fact, because it frames everything that follows.
The Danish state has existed as an independent state, without interruption, for more than one thousand years.
Seen from an international perspective, that is quite unique.
Over that long story, Denmark has had several different forms of government.
But every single one of them had the monarchy as its form of state.
What changed was the role the king played.
Today, the king is still formally the head of state, but it is the elected politicians who hold the political power.
Denmark has also spent most of its history as a power in the Nordic region and around the Baltic Sea.
It once held many different population groups, and has gradually been reduced to a small state with a fairly uniform population.
Hold on to that arc, from regional power to small state, because we are going to watch it unfold.
One small tip about the textbook itself.
When a year range appears in brackets after a king or queen, it means their reign.
So Frederik the Third, with the years sixteen forty-eight to seventy, reigned from sixteen forty-eight to sixteen seventy.
For anyone else, the years in brackets are their lifetime.
For example, the author Karen Blixen, eighteen eighty-five to nineteen sixty-two, lived from 1885 to 1962.
Now, our story starts in the Viking Age, roughly the year 750 to the year 1050.
This is the period when Denmark was gathered under one king, and power began to be centralised.
The Vikings sailed out across Europe, where they traded, raided, and settled.
And it was also in this period that most Danes became Christian.
First, a correction to the popular image.
Vikings are often described as brutal warriors, and some of them certainly were.
But in reality, the vast majority of people in the Viking Age were farmers who worked the land and kept animals, or they were merchants who bought and sold goods.
So how did a kingdom take shape?
The first known king was named Angantyr.
Already around the year 700, he gathered part of the area that would later become Denmark.
The word "Denmark" itself is known from the end of the 800s.
"Dan" comes from "daner", the people who lived in the Danish area, and "mark" means border area.
So Denmark means "the Danes' borderland".
The first time the name Denmark appears inside the country's own borders is on a so-called runestone from around the year 955.
It was raised by King Gorm the Old, in memory of his wife, Thyra.
A runestone is called that because the text is written in runes, the writing signs of the Viking Age.
Gorm and Thyra's son was Harald Bluetooth, in Danish, Harald Blåtand.
He is regarded as the first king to rule all of Denmark, and he was also king over parts of Norway.
Around the year 965, in the 900s, Harald raised a runestone of his own.
Both stones stand today in the town of Jelling, in Jutland.
To protect his kingdom against enemies, Harald Bluetooth built a series of ring fortresses around the year 980.
Remember the names.
Aggersborg and Fyrkat in North Jutland.
Nonnebakken on Funen.
And Trelleborg and Borgring on Zealand.
Trelleborg lies near Slagelse in West Zealand.
By the standards of the time, these were huge building projects.
And they tell us something important: the king had the power to collect taxes and to organise huge amounts of labour.
That shows Denmark was one kingdom, gathered under one central power.
Now let's follow the Vikings abroad.
They had a lot of contact with the outside world, and the development of the Viking ships made that possible.
These ships were both more solid and more flexible than earlier ships.
They could sail the open sea even in difficult conditions, travel quickly, and even sail up rivers to towns that were not on the coast.
The Vikings traded with the rest of Europe, and they also had contact with the Arab countries.
But not everything was peaceful trade.
In the 800s, Danish Vikings also went on raids, to England and France, and as far away as Constantinople, today's Istanbul.
On these raids they plundered monasteries and towns and demanded tax from the locals.
They also conquered large areas of land, and some Vikings settled in the places they conquered.
One example is Normandy in France.
Then comes the high point.
The Danish king Svend Forkbeard, Svend Tveskæg, who reigned from nine eighty-seven to ten fourteen, conquered England, and became its king in the year 1013, that is, in the 1000s.
His son, Cnut the Great, Knud den Store, reigned from ten eighteen to ten thirty-five.
He was also king of England, and he ruled Norway as well, at the moment when the Viking empire was at its largest.
But that great kingdom fell apart again quickly.
Yet the Vikings left lasting marks in England.
The English people took in many words from the Vikings' language, Old Norse, which is the forerunner of modern Danish.
Modern English is estimated to contain a couple of hundred words from Old Norse.
Examples: egg, window, knife, law, and sell.
Now, what did the Vikings believe?
In the Danish area, people practised a Nordic religion called Asatru, which means belief in the Aesir, who were gods.
Central to it were sacrifices, rituals and ceremonies in which gifts were given to the gods.
These could be jewellery, food, tools, but also animals and people, who were killed for the occasion.
This could take place in nature, at special holy places such as forests, springs or bogs, or by the houses where the Vikings lived.
The king of the gods was Odin.
He is often described as an older man with only one eye and two ravens sitting on his shoulders.
Among the other gods: Freja, goddess of fertility, and Thor, god of thunder and war, who drove across the sky in his chariot.
According to the myth, that was the sound people heard when it thundered.
Thor's hammer was called Mjølner.
And these gods live on in the Danish language.
Wednesday, onsdag, comes from Odin, and Thursday, torsdag, from Thor.
Many place names have roots in mythology too.
Odense comes from "Odin's vi", meaning Odin's sanctuary.
And Tórshavn, the largest town in the Faroe Islands, is of course Thor's harbour.
But then something new arrived: Christianity came to Denmark in the Viking Age, and slowly replaced the old religion.
The German missionary Ansgar built churches in the middle of the 800s in Hedeby and Ribe.
And around the year 965, Harald Bluetooth was baptised.
The runestone he raised at Jelling says that King Harald won all of Denmark and Norway for himself and made the Danes Christian.
That is why Harald's Jelling stone is often called "Denmark's baptismal certificate".
A good one to remember for the exam.
So that is the Viking Age.
Now we step into the Middle Ages, roughly ten fifty to fifteen hundred.
This was an age in which the king, the church and the nobility often fought each other for power.
Over time, royal power and church grew closer together.
And it was also a period of important innovations, such as the Jutland Law, and of the worst plague in Danish history, the Black Death.
And finally, the whole of the Nordic region was gathered in one union, the Kalmar Union.
Let's start with the struggle for power.
After Cnut the Great died in ten thirty-five, an unstable period followed.
A number of Danish kings were murdered, which weakened royal power.
A famous example is Knud the Holy, Knud den Hellige, who reigned from ten eighty to eighty-six.
He was killed in Saint Alban's Church in Odense in the year 1086 by the magnates, the richest men in the country.
They were unhappy that they had to pay fines to the king if they did not take part in military service.
And that murder made one thing clear: in the future, kings could only rule if they made agreements with the magnates.
These agreements developed into real contracts about how power should be shared between the king and the magnates.
They were called håndfæstninger.
The first håndfæstning was signed in 1282 by Erik Klipping, who reigned from twelve fifty-nine to eighty-six.
The last was signed by Frederik the Third in 1648.
It was then cancelled when the absolute hereditary monarchy was introduced in sixteen sixty to sixty-one.
Remember that: first in 1282, last in 1648.
Meanwhile the church was changing too.
For the first hundred years or more after Harald Bluetooth was baptised, Christianity in Denmark was subject to the Archbishop of Hamburg-Bremen in Germany, who was strongly influenced by the German emperors.
That weakened the Danish king, and so Denmark's independence.
But during the 1000s an independent Danish church emerged.
It was divided into eight dioceses, that is, geographical areas administered by the church with a bishop as the top leader.
Then, in the year 1103, Lund in Skåne, which was part of Denmark until 1658, got its own archbishop, with the whole Nordic region under him.
The North thereby became an independent church area, as part of the Catholic church, directly under the Pope in Rome, and independent of the German emperor's power.
A few hundred years after Christianity was introduced, the church had become very powerful.
It was an important part of every person's everyday life.
People had to pay a tax to the church called tithe, "tiende", because it was one tenth of the harvest or other production.
The church largely decided what people were allowed to believe, how to live, and which actions were right and which were wrong, or sinful.
The centre of faith was the town's or village's church, and around 1250, up to three thousand churches had been built in Denmark.
People went there to pray to God, and to receive forgiveness from the priest if they had, in the church's eyes, done something wrong.
Forgiveness of sin could often be bought by paying money to the church, which was called indulgence, "aflad".
And the church service, the mass, every Sunday created reconciliation between God and people.
Monasteries were also built, where monks and nuns could live the perfect Christian life.
Many monasteries also took care of the sick and the poor.
The church soon came to own large areas of land in Denmark, and the Catholic church was an international organisation with great influence in Europe.
So the medieval Danish kings had to make sure the church was on their side.
From the middle of the 1100s to the middle of the 1200s, royal power regained strength.
And that can be seen in a number of laws made at this time, of which the best known is the Jutland Law, Jyske Lov, from the year 1241.
Now it was the king who made the laws.
This was important for the Danish legal society in the Middle Ages.
Before, families had taken revenge on each other when crimes were committed.
The Jutland Law rejected this kind of blood revenge.
It also abolished large parts of customary law, which was based on unwritten rules.
The sentence "With law shall the land be built", "Med lov skal man land bygge", comes from the introduction to the Jutland Law.
At first the law applied only in Jutland, but large parts of it were later written into the Danish Law of 1683, the first common law for the whole of Denmark.
The 1200s also saw Danish kings carry out a number of crusades.
These were military actions in the Baltic area to convert pagan, that is non-Christian, populations to Christianity.
One of the best known went to Estonia in 1219.
The story goes that during a battle near Tallinn, the Dannebrog fell down from the sky and made sure the Danes won the battle.
Now to the plague, and the union.
From the middle of the 1200s, Denmark was marked by division and civil war, which increased in the first half of the 1300s.
King Valdemar Atterdag, who reigned from thirteen forty to seventy-five, managed to gather the Danish kingdom again and rebuild state power.
During his reign, the plague called the Black Death raged.
It hit Denmark and the rest of Europe around 1350, and killed up to half of the population.
That is the 1300s.
Yet the tragedy strengthened the king's power, because he took over much of the land that had belonged to those who died of the plague.
After Valdemar Atterdag died in 1375, his daughter Margrete the First took power.
She also became regent in Norway, which at that time included the Faroe Islands, Iceland and parts of Greenland.
And in 1397 she gathered Denmark, Norway and Sweden, which at that time also included Finland, in a union with Denmark as the dominant power.
This was called the Kalmar Union, because the union treaty was signed in the Swedish town of Kalmar.
The Kalmar Union was finally dissolved in 1523, when Sweden broke free for good.
Norway stayed in union with Denmark until 1814.
Margrete is buried in Roskilde Cathedral.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which three countries formed the Kalmar Union in 1397?
Option A: Denmark, Sweden and England.
Option B: Denmark, Norway and Sweden.
Option C: Denmark, England and Norway.
[DA] Hvilke tre lande dannede Kalmarunionen i 1397?  A: Danmark, Sverige og England  |  B: Danmark, Norge og Sverige  |  C: Danmark, England og Norge
The answer is B: Denmark, Norway and Sweden.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Danmark, Norge og Sverige
Question 2.
Which king had it written on one of the Jelling stones that he made the Danes Christian?
Option A: Svend Forkbeard.
Option B: Harald Bluetooth.
Option C: Valdemar the Victorious.
[DA] Hvilken konge fik skrevet på den ene af Jellingstenene, at han gjorde danskerne (danerne) kristne?  A: Svend Tveskæg  |  B: Harald Blåtand  |  C: Valdemar Sejr
The answer is B: Harald Bluetooth.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Harald Blåtand
Question 3.
When did King Harald Bluetooth have it written on one of the Jelling stones that he made the Danes Christian?
Option A: The 900s.
Option B: The 1200s.
Option C: The 1500s.
[DA] Hvornår fik kong Harald Blåtand skrevet på den ene af Jellingstenene, at han gjorde danerne (danskerne) kristne?  A: 900-tallet  |  B: 1200-tallet  |  C: 1500-tallet
The answer is A: The 900s.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: 900-tallet
Question 4.
Which are names of gods in the Viking religion Asatro?
Option A: Thyra and Gorm.
Option B: Ingrid and Absalon.
Option C: Freja and Thor.
[DA] Hvilke af følgende er navne på guder i vikingetidens religion 'asatroen'?  A: Thyra og Gorm  |  B: Ingrid og Absalon  |  C: Freja og Thor
The answer is C: Freja and Thor.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Freja og Thor
Question 5.
Which religion was the most widespread in Denmark in the Middle Ages, roughly 1050 to 1500?
Option A: Orthodox Christianity.
Option B: Catholic Christianity.
Option C: Protestant Christianity.
[DA] Hvilken religion var den mest udbredte i Danmark i middelalderen (cirka 1050-1500)?  A: Ortodoks kristendom  |  B: Katolsk kristendom  |  C: Protestantisk kristendom
The answer is B: Catholic Christianity.
It appeared in the June 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Katolsk kristendom
Question 6.
What characterised Denmark in the Middle Ages, 1050 to 1500?
Option A: Denmark got colonies in Africa and the Caribbean.
Option B: Thousands of churches were built.
Option C: Denmark got a democratic constitution.
[DA] Hvad kendetegnede Danmark i middelalderen (1050-1500)?  A: Danmark fik kolonier i Afrika og Caribien  |  B: Der blev bygget tusindvis af kirker  |  C: Danmark fik en demokratisk grundlov
The answer is B: Thousands of churches were built.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Der blev bygget tusindvis af kirker
Question 7.
When was Denmark hit by the plague epidemic the Black Death, which killed a large part of the population?
Option A: In the 1300s.
Option B: In the 1600s.
Option C: In the 1900s.
[DA] Hvornår blev Danmark ramt af pest-epidemien Den Sorte Død, som slog en stor del af befolkningen ihjel?  A: I 1300-tallet  |  B: I 1600-tallet  |  C: I 1900-tallet
The answer is A: In the 1300s.
It appeared in the November 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: I 1300-tallet
Question 8.
In which century was England conquered by the Danish king Svend Forkbeard?
Option A: The 1000s.
Option B: The 1300s.
Option C: The 1600s.
[DA] I hvilket århundrede blev England erobret af den danske konge Svend Tveskæg?  A: 1000-tallet  |  B: 1300-tallet  |  C: 1600-tallet
The answer is A: The 1000s.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: 1000-tallet
Question 9.
Which of these countries was conquered by Svend Forkbeard in the 1000s?
Option A: France.
Option B: Poland.
Option C: England.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende lande blev erobret af Svend Tveskæg i 1000-tallet?  A: Frankrig  |  B: Polen  |  C: England
The answer is C: England.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: England
Question 10.
Who gathered Denmark, Norway and Sweden in a union at the end of the 1300s?
Option A: Cnut the Great.
Option B: Margrete the First.
Option C: Christian the Third.
[DA] Hvem samlede i slutningen af 1300-tallet Danmark, Norge og Sverige i en union?  A: Knud den Store  |  B: Margrete den 1.  |  C: Christian den 3.
The answer is B: Margrete the First.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Margrete den 1.
Question 11.
What is the largest town in the Faroe Islands called?
Option A: Reykjavik.
Option B: Nuuk.
Option C: Tórshavn.
[DA] Hvad hedder Færøernes største by?  A: Reykjavik  |  B: Nuuk  |  C: Tórshavn
The answer is C: Tórshavn.
It appeared in the November 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Tórshavn
That's the end of Part One of Episode 1.
In Part Two, we continue with the Reformation, the Swedish wars and absolutism.
See you there.